[Music]
you
hi I'm will Torres and I'm joined by my
colleague Tiffany Baroni Manolo we're
going to be talking about financial aid
here at Stanford GSB and we're gonna be
going over some frequently answered
questions in today's conversation we're
going to talk about who should apply for
financial aid when you should apply and
the types of aid available to you after
we go through the basics we're gonna
bring in some current students who went
through the financial aid process and
will be sharing their experiences there
are two terms - no need blind and
need-based the admission process is
need-blind which means we're not taking
into account how you're gonna pay for
your education when we're making those
admissions decisions the financial aid
process happens after you're admitted
and financial aid here at Stanford is
need-based that means you're gonna be
working with our financial aid officers
to take a look at your financial
circumstances to figure out a financial
aid package that will support you during
your time here the financial aid process
is centered around our schools guiding
principles of access equity and
excellence we want every student who is
admitted to be able to engage and
participate to the fullest extent during
their time here to do this we've
developed a financial aid process to
treat students consistently and
equitably while supporting the GSB s
efforts to attract the most competitive
and diverse class possible we understand
that a Stanford degree is an investment
in you and your future and we hope that
with our financial aid support you'll be
able to make that investment with the
goal of supporting those who need it the
most with the most aid so I'm going to
provide you with a general overview of
financial aid at Stanford GSB so all
admitted students into the MBA and MSX
program are eligible to apply for
need-based fellowship and loans loans
are specific based off of your
citizenship we determine your cost of
attendance based off of your unique
financial situation so marital status as
well as family size your cost of
attendance takes into consideration your
tuition living expenses housing charges
health insurance etc we determine your
student contribution based off of the
information reported in your application
we take into consideration special
circumstances which would include
medical expenses
support to family as well as your family
size on average 50% of our students
receive a need-based fellowship which
equates to about 76 thousand dollars for
the two-year MBA program and $50,000 for
the one year MSX program the GSB has an
expectation that all students will
contribute a portion of their income and
assets towards their educational costs
one of the most commonly question asked
questions that I get is how do you
determine a student's fellowship
eligibility yes that is a typical
question that we received from
perspective admitted students so in
order to determine somebody's need-based
fellowship eligibility we're going to
look at their income and assets to
determine their student contribution
which is what they should be able to
contribute towards their education we
take that student contribution plus a
base loan and deduct it from their costs
of attendance to determine what their
financial need is of that financial need
we're going to give as much as we can in
need-based fellowship and the rest would
come in the form of loans which are
specific based off your citizenship and
just coming from lived experience life
is complicated so how do you take into
account personal and/or like unique
circumstances from applicants yeah
that's a great question so within our
financial aid application we have a
section specifically for students to
call outs with unique financial
situations and provide us contacts and
we will review them and take them into
consideration on a case-by-case basis
all right and then what about folks who
are thinking about nonprofit or public
sector areas historically that might
have a different pay trajectory yeah so
what's really amazing is that the GSB
offers a loan forgiveness program for
both the mba and MSX alumni who are
working in a non-profit public service
sector great and how do you consider
folks coming from outside of the United
States so international versus US
citizens
yeah so for us for financial aid
purposes we treat both internationals
and USS and permanent residents exactly
the same in our financial aid algorithm
to determine need-based aid eligibility
so whatever one student will get will be
the same that somebody else would get in
the calculation right and then what if
I'm coming to the GSB with a spouse or
children how do you take that into
account yeah so if you're coming with a
spouse or children we're gonna use a
higher cost of attendance because you
have higher expenses when we're
determining your student your student
contribution as well as your fellowship
eligibility in addition Stanford
University as a whole offers a family
grant program that will offer further
assistance to individuals who are coming
with dependent children yeah
and let's say I admit I'm admitted
I'm applying for financial aid and that
supports really important to how I'm
deciding where I'm gonna go are there
any tools or places you could point me
to to help at least ballpark what I
might get yes so that's a really good
question and we actually have a
financial aid calculator available on
the my GSP website once you're admitted
into the program where you can put in
your information that we would ask for
in your financial aid application and
get a range for what your student
contribution would be as well as your
need-based fellowship eligibility so
that would help you get some informed
decisions about whether or not you want
to go through the process yeah and then
final question do you have any tips best
practices or things I should consider as
I'm thinking about funding my b-school
education so one of the first things is
we say start with the website because
all the contents available there for you
to understand how to apply for aid what
aids available to you and a leader type
in nuances and then always reach out to
our office because we're here to be your
help to be helpful to you to answer any
questions to get you through the process
and it's a conversation so don't be
afraid to tell us about a special
circumstance that's going on in your
life because it might be something we
can take into consideration thank you
and so with that we invite you to learn
more about financial aid at for both the
NBA and the MSX programs log on GSB dot
stanford.edu to learn more
[Music]